are you self-destructive tough
am i
anytime that anything and good happens
in my life i'm instantly like worried
oh [ __ ] how am i gonna [ __ ] this up you
know what i mean
i'm like standing right in front of him
it's not like you know catwalk elevated
everybody's on the same kind of field
and boom right at the end of the runways
kanye west who's staring at me i'm
staring at him
it was it was a [ __ ] moment
and you ended up down here somehow
somehow
well it's you know my own [ __ ] i i
can't i'm not going to sit here and like
blame anybody you know what i mean i had
a i had a pretty good childhood being a
trust fund kid you know but it left me
like
desiring more
um
[Music]
relationship wise like out of people
like i became very clingy very needy
because i was raised by au pairs mainly
and
you know most of them didn't even really
speak that that good english because my
mom didn't want you know
uh
you know some [ __ ] french maid you
know running around our house so he had
you know consuela or
maria
and uh there's who i spent most of my
time with you know and you know you
could talk to them and they'd say yeah
it's easy but you know that they're not
really clicking on what you're telling
them you grew up where north carolina
charlotte north carolina charlotte and
uh
you had mom and dad mom and dad um
just aside from the fact that they were
doing business all the time it's not
that they were neglectful people it's
just that they were very hard working we
owned our own company um computers
and uh
you know my dad was just invested in
that a lot and my mom got involved as
well
um so like i said i'll you know earlier
there's two ways you could get attention
in my family you know and it's like my
sister my older sister you could
accomplish things get on the valk
victorians list you know
be really good at school or sports or
you could call it the principal's office
every day you know and force my dad to
fly out to come and see me you know
that's what you that's the path yeah
that's the kind of yeah that's the path
i took you know i didn't realize that
that's what i was doing until like i
kind of worked through that you know
i've been to rehab since i was 16 man
um
christian family super strict very
protective
um
and you know as soon as i started you
know smoking a little pot they you know
they worried and sent me off
and that's kind of like what i got used
to being sent off so it wasn't like you
had this terrible traumatic childhood no
you had a great childhood it sounds like
yeah but you just other than like inside
and i didn't have many many friends but
at the same time like i played guitar
you know i i had a whole studio because
my dad played guitar so you know i had
all the tools to be a happy child all
the tools my younger brother is very
happy and successful my older sister's
very happily successful it's just are
you the black sheep of the family i'm a
box shoot
you went through high school i did i got
kicked out freshman year uh fell in with
the wrong crowd
the gangster types
and my dad had built the whole mainframe
for the school
so he had a key to every room
and one day some little thug came up to
me and was like hey his name is preston
he uh
it's like hey
i saw like five thousand dollars worth
of booster money you know miss carpenter
hat or something and
i didn't even need the money or anything
i just wanted to be like have friends
you know have like a group of people
that you know thought i was the dude you
know high fives back me up be like a
gangster
and the school that i went to is a
charter school so it was like half
private school kids half like oh they
won the lottery and now their kids are
here
type thing and uh that was like a big
culture shock you know because you have
these two mix of people you know these
people that are on welfare and then you
have these people that
summer in italy you know what i mean
and uh
i had grown up with all the kids this
summer in italy and they never really
liked me and tried to fit in with them
and
then the kids that were smoking pot and
doing crimes
you know whether it was that they
thought that they could get something
from me or you know money or or whatever
were nice to me and doubted me up made
me feel like i was cool so i stole the
key to my dad's
to every room in the school
and uh took everything from the school
laptops uh computers anything that
wasn't nailed down and some things that
were
um next day we went to school acted like
nothing had happened uh homework got
canceled which i was really happy about
um because i hadn't done it
um
and then preston makes uh
he
he's gone you know what i mean my
parents he took the key my parents
noticed that the key was gone and boom
all signs point towards john so
they made me go down to
the police department and
they made me uh they were trying to make
me confess to doing it and that in that
moment i think i kind of made a choice
that like affected me the rest of my
life that
i was going to be a gangster i was going
to be the rebel i was going to be you
know
james jean rebel without a cause you
know the reason i ride a motorcycle
and in that moment you know i'm not
saying anything my parents i think had
decided as well like you know we've done
all we can for him
and then that's when they made the
decision to uh send me off to teen
challenge uh
newport news it was like a intensive
inpatient bad kids
type thing and i was uh
you know i kind of wore it as a badge
but at the same time you know boom now
i'm i'm a teenage kid stuck with a bunch
of dudes and uh you know my pride my
privacy's gone my freedom's gone
you know uh
my
i can't talk to i can't even look at
girls it's against the program you know
and i had a girlfriend at the time her
mom had died of cancer and that was my
out you know because they didn't tell me
about the funeral until afterwards so i
made a huge big stink about
you know oh i can't be here i have to be
there for carson this time the other
i've learned enough and i have been
there for seven months already
i go back and things are good for
a little while but but during this time
my parents had moved out
to an estate in the country in monroe
so they had uh
like big amounts of land but
there was nowhere to get drugs there was
nowhere to get alcohol there was no
people around and i would just go stir
crazy there you know and i had
anger problems from just being a spoiled
little [ __ ] you know um
and that was another thing you know my
parents couldn't deal with have me in
counseling and stuff and
before i knew it you know i'm turning 18
and and it's time to go you know what i
mean it's like you got to get out of my
house
or go to college i did that for a little
while
and um
had like a summer internship in new york
doing banking you know at goldman sachs
and
decided i didn't want to do it you know
i was like this is lame uh and i saw in
the night life while i was in new york
you know there's like two people there's
the bankers and then there's the models
and like musicians and such you know
there's money and then the beautiful
people
and beautiful people love the money
because they pay for everything the
people with money love the beautiful
people because they make them look cool
you know what i mean
and i decided that i didn't want to be
one of the people fronting the money i
wanted to be one of the beautiful people
you know and i had a modeling agency
from down in
north carolina called evolution that i
was with it's a
will mean is the parent company
and they set me up with interviews all
over new york to to to model and i'm
getting turned down by ford elite you
know everybody's turning me down too
short we love your look but you're too
short and
you're six foot right six foot six foot
that's too short that's too short it's
about two inches too short you know and
it wasn't way too short so they were
like immediately like get out of here
they were like looking at me they would
bite their lips they would wonder
themselves maybe you know
and uh i lucked out you know creative
director of burberry had somehow got
across my shots from my agent at the
time recorders
and uh boom it was
you know
all uphill or downhill however you want
to look at it from there
yeah you got an agent
you see well i mean uh indiana
and uh yeah
and uh you know i did that for a little
while did you know his jet set you know
not famous not billboards and everything
but i still got to live the life which
was you know all i really cared about um
you know i was with the models i got to
meet the designers um i got an old
designer wardrobe that like i'm
continually getting stolen or losing
nowadays
and
then i would get bored i started getting
bored i was in new york and you know i i
just like my dad and his his dad you
know we all we need something to do you
know we need a purpose or else we like i
said go stir crazy
so i would pick up my guitar and i would
walk all around downtown new york
looking for like places to play you know
maybe a
um
maybe a
open mic here open mic there
not even an open mic sometimes i would
just walk into coffee shops be like hey
do you guys mind if i play a couple
songs sometimes they'd be like [ __ ] off
sometimes they'd be like yeah sure just
don't be too loud
and i'm playing at a place called the
cup
and uh
in long in long island actually
and uh andy aiella from sony comes in
and uh she she walks past me loves my
sounds interrupts me in the middle of me
playing to hand me a card
told me to meet him the next day i do
and
you know i ended up signing like a
little [ __ ] contract with them gave
me 75 000
and uh started vetting me to like
um
you know do bigger shows and stuff like
we were really just like an opening act
um but i didn't see it that way you know
i mean with all the crowds that i would
go to play for like they were there for
me in my eyes and even when i would lead
worship at like churches you know what
i'm saying like
i'd see everybody worshiping and i just
like i'd really internalize that like
they're here for you they're here for
you they're here for you because my
whole life
you know i grew up with this like
stigmatism that like i don't know if
that's the right word that like you know
everything had fallen into my lap so i
had like this big god complex that you
know
you can call it narcissism you can call
it whatever you want and
i just thought that i was invincible
like i played russian roulette with
myself during like suicidal rants like
just
just just this overall
feeling that like the world was mine and
i was invincible you know probably most
young people have that but i really
pushed it to the edge as fast as i can
could you know base jumping doing
anything i could to excite myself
and uh
like i said uh
that all that kind of went to my head
with sony so
they ended up giving me multiple chances
to turn it all around and then finally
they they brought us all in you know
maybe after a year
maybe not even and told us all like if
we all had to go to separate 30-day
rehabs or
you know they were going to drop us
you're banned
yeah and uh
at the time i had uh
kind of been like talking with some
people at sub pop and capital but we
didn't have the 275 000
breach of contract to break the contract
with them and sign with someone else
so when there was even kind of like
whispers that you know they were going
to drop us it was like
please you know you mean let us go let's
go and
not realizing sony's like a bankroll and
you know like you don't sleep in a bus
when you're on tour with sony you know
what i mean you get a hotel and like
that brings me like this one time i was
at the ritz carlton trying to be jimmy
page very hard and i threw a tv out of
the window and got hit with a reckless
endangerment charge thinking that the
next day that it was going to be in the
news young musician john slayton
wasn't you know what i mean ended up
spending some time in jail and banned at
the ritz carlton
um just trying to be a rock star like
because that's all i cared about as a
kid going and growing up dude it's just
being a rock star being a rock star
everybody thinking i'm a rock star you
know this big ladies man you know
this big facade you know like
i would after like watching the doors
movie for example you know what i mean i
wanted to be jim morrison so bad but
anyway so
after
during that meeting you know i gave him
the bird was like
drop us and you know
will be fine type thing i don't think i
told him about
our offers or
you know thought of offers
um but he made it clear that like you
know
we were done you know what i mean
started ripping our stuff off youtube
took our instagram page down like if you
type in prideful lion like nothing comes
up like shows used to come up my songs
used to come up like thing like i used
to have 275 000 followers on instagram
like you know i was really doing it and
i was on my way to being you know bigger
and i just put a big i built a brick
wall right in front of that train that i
was riding
and i hit it and i hit it hard
and uh when they dropped us we flew all
the way up to seattle to go to um talk
to our contacts at subpop and
verbatim like when we got there usually
it's cucumber water and please have a
seat in my office and then this time
it's you know he'll be out to see you
and a water bottle you know what i mean
not the cucumber artisan water because i
was really looking forward to that
and they hand us a water bottle and
we're sitting out there for probably
about 45 minutes you know what i mean
and i start getting the sinking feeling
in my stomach like this is not good this
is not good at all because every other
time it was let me take you out to
dinner to get some drinks like wine and
dine type thing and now
you know we're waiting for 45 minutes
and he comes out and he's got he's like
hey guys it's good to see you shakes all
our hands and i'm i start as soon as he
comes out i start walking back to his
office you know what he means i'm
thinking you know come on back so hold
on a second uh let me just talk to you
real quick right here
and he tells me um
i've got insider information that you
guys will be more of a liability than an
asset to our company at this time so
we're gonna have to pass on you guys
right now you know i threw a big fit
knocked over a vase turned out to be
plastic didn't even break
and uh we left to fly back down to la to
come and maybe see if capital would do
this you know would take us now
even though we were trying to like lean
away from the bigger labels because we
thought we were in indie band and uh
same exact thing dude colin mullin at
our uh
that's uh capital comes out he's like um
uh
we got insider information that should
be more of a liability than asset to our
company at the time you know i mean it
says verbatim those same words
two weeks after that
my drummer overdoses and dies
and then like exactly two weeks after
that my bass player
[Music]
dies of an overdose that they you know
like could have been ruled a suicide
kind of i i don't remember what they
were saying like i was just kind of in
shock
that that had happened and then my band
kind of like broke up
um i still make music it's just i
haven't been able to find a band i'm 27
now and all this happened right around
1920 you know
and uh i haven't been able to find
anybody that i have a chemistry with
since but i've been making music i got
picked up by another label
and during that time like 20
to
25 or 26
i'm just
really running the rails like i've got
all these contacts from my time modeling
and doing music for people that like i
learned
if you keep the fact that you need help
to yourself
they are more apt to help you you know
what i mean
like
if soon as you go to them saying hey i'm
about to be homeless i need some money
or a place to stay it's uh you're poor
you're
a vagrant you're a drug addict and you
can be doing the same drugs as them you
know
so i learned that after burning a couple
bridges with people you know
really high profile contacts that like
i've you know really really appreciated
keeping you know
and uh
like the only one that didn't was steven
tyler and he he
was just all about making me go to like
midnight mission actually not down not
too far from here
because uh at the time he had known that
i was more
ritzy and gone to like richer kind of
rehabs and he thought that maybe going
to like a super
dilapidated and
just disgusting is the only way i can
think even though it's a great place and
changes lots of lives i will say that
not to not to knock the midnight mission
um because it did a lot for me too
uh but
i started learning that you know
my
my look
does not have to go with my life kind of
thing i started learning that you know
not everybody needs to know what's going
on in my life
and that's when i really started like
lying to people you know i would really
i would crash at their vacation homes
for you know weeks at a time oh i'm just
in town for a little bit
something happened with the hotels oh of
course you can come of course of course
we would be happy to have you type thing
yeah and
and i i let that ride for as long as i
could could i would call it couchsurfing
but you know it was rare that i slept on
a couch you know i'd sometimes have my
own guesthouse or
you know just be out the house by myself
and
i did that for as long as i could
knowing in the back of my mind that this
was not sustainable that this was not
something that
i'm gonna go go anywhere on and
ironically enough my biggest fear in
life is wasted potential you know having
the ability to do more and not
and that's all i was doing for five six
years just no i had all these songs that
i could have been recording this album i
could have got done and all these people
that wanted to support me doing it like
even now as i'm talking to you
i've got
almost 40 000 followers on instagram you
know what i mean and
they don't know
like i'm just
barely barely by the skin of my teeth
you know i now i am on a couch you know
i i am
sleeping on uh someone's couch just
because it was a friend was
you know good enough to like try and
help me get sober and get out of that
you know lifestyle and you know
it's so hard
even now you know i got a scooter to do
like doordash and everything it's just
like this big culture shock over these
years that you think i'd be used to by
now and it's still not
like
i feel like this is just a like a
distant dream still you know what i mean
like being on this
i've slept outside but it took a long
time until i had to sleep out i i slept
outside like if it ever got that close i
would always go to a rehab you know i
mean because back then i had that
ability i'd been clean off of heroin for
a while
and then when this accident happened i
got back on heroin and it wouldn't do
anything to me after i left the hospital
they had me on so many opiates and so
many things and i've been sober up until
that moment that when i got to the
hospital i started getting dope sick
did like two grams of heroin and it
didn't do anything to me and i and i
thought oh man
this is where i'm gonna have to stop
it's not doing anything for me not even
making me not sick so let me just quit
it and
if i would have just done that it
probably wouldn't be in the situation i
am now but somebody offered me fentanyl
and
described it to me as like heroin on
heroin you know or heroin on crack or
whatever you want to say
yeah fed no and my first time doing it
like
woke up
sleeping on my arm and my arm was like
asleep
and
i couldn't move my hands
um
i couldn't feel my arm you know for a
little while and it came back thank god
uh
that was scary bro that was a really
scary moment i'm in an abandoned
building
after i just got kicked out of a
a
a physical therapy spot
um for getting in a fight with someone
just being an idiot getting a fist fight
with some [ __ ]
homeless vagrant you know someone i
wouldn't have even talked to before
and got in a fight with him because he
bugged me so much i let him get under my
skin that much
and
boom i'm asked out and calling people
and
my one of my friends had
said come to the hollywood highlands
hotel
i got a room for you so i go there in my
wheelchair
and i i know up there and
he's not showing up not answering the
phones but the guy at the front desk
knew that he had told me that he was
going to get me a room he ends up
putting me in a room the guy at the
hotel that's not paid for yet because
he's under the impression that the
friend is going to come and pay for it
so i'm in this hotel room kind of
wondering what my next move is going to
be and they're already telling me the
next day that i got to go
and so i'm standing out you know trying
to get out of my wheelchair as much as
possible i had the cast on it's been
about a year or two that i've had this
on
and
someone offers me fentanyl and i'm like
you know hey i don't have anywhere to go
right now do you have a spot
and he takes me like across the street
to this abandoned building
where we stay in the basement and he's
like you know tweaked it out
to where he's got you know electricity
running to this room in the back part of
the basement he's got this board that we
can take off of the window and like kind
of sneak in and with my leg
i fell down more than once
trying to get in that place
but um
he showed me that spot and and gave me
that fentanyl and i'm in the basement of
of a [ __ ] abandoned
apartment building
you know almost dead
and and no one would have known that i
died no one probably would have found me
for a week you know unless he came in
and saw me and i think that he would
have just buried me under garbage you
know rather than deal with a
dead body or just left
and not said anything you know that's
the people that i was i started hanging
around
i'm living in an abandoned building
and then wandering the streets of
hollywood just just
trying to
breeding everybody my contacts was dry
for money and cash out my parents who
had cut me off financially long ago
you know making up little stories here
and there like using my leg isn't it you
know excuse to get money for drugs like
oh i need ace band traps or i need this
i need that
and um
uh
i did that as long as i i could and
i ended up uh
where did i go next i
i ended up getting back into that
physical therapy spot eventually but i
had to get my leg infected first for
cedar cyanide to admit me
in order to put me in there
and i almost i did that like two or
three more times
and
stayed there for like two or three more
months there's a couple times where it
looked like my life was about to turn
around
you know i'd get back involved in
alcoholics and i must get a couple days
sober here get a couple days over here
not even be sober but try and lie to
them to see if they'll house me or
something you know got a sponsor for a
little while was calling him and doing
all the steps and stuff but still
smoking fat and all like
like nothing had happened you know just
being depressed and
alone out here needing some friends so i
oh did i get close
um
so i needed you know
uh
just people to be around me which was
like you know my biggest problem as a
kid i was you know always alone and
never really wanted to be alone did you
ever think when you were a kid you know
you come from a charmed
life
your parents were great it sounds like
you came from a wealthy
family
you had great opportunities you're
handsome as can be
you speak beautifully
it's almost like you had it too easy
yeah that's why i look at it you know
everything just kind of fell in my life
you never had to fight or struggle or
overcome anything it's kind of like it
was not really you know i mean the
willamena like when i was walking around
new york to go to all the agencies it
was it was difficult like google mapsing
and getting over here and over there and
that was the most difficult part of that
process
you know i didn't have to call a
thousand different photographers and
build up a portfolio like i showed up
with some some pictures from a friend of
mine from north carolina that does
weddings and all she really had to do is
take pictures of me you know what i mean
and that was good enough for them
because they looked at me and knew
that i had the look and and what i was
capable of is there's something inside
you in your subconscious maybe that
feels like you don't you don't believe
you deserve this
this this life not this right now but
with the success that you had earlier oh
yeah i mean i was always questioning
your band took off quickly your modeling
career took off instantly i was always
worried that people were gonna know find
out i was a fraud you know i mean that
this is the last good song that i'm
gonna write this is the last you know
thing i'm gonna do and after that
everybody's gonna realize oh he was a
one-trick pony
you know and and that moment never came
you know that moment never
it was just continual like i i grew
matured in my music and my art and and
just kept getting better and the better
i would get it was like the
worst i would i would be off so what's
your what's the doubt what's the reason
for your downfall
fentanyl
fentanyl i can't
and and and misdirection you know when i
was during that period when i was like
before you hurt your leg
it's alcohol
yeah you're you're still playing around
with you're still playing around with
drugs yeah so you can't blame fentanyl i
guess not uh
i've always just kind of i've always
been
weed drugs i mean uh
uh cocaine meth uh are you
self-destructive soft
am i
anytime that anything and good happens
in my life i'm instantly like worried
oh [ __ ] how am i gonna [ __ ] this up you
know what i mean
you know it's almost like i'm more
comfortable in chaos and misery because
i know that well
i won't say it can't get worse than this
because that's happened multiple times
but uh i kind of always see like you're
in an abandoned building
you know why why can't i shoot some pet
no my life sucks you know what i mean so
boom i do it and my life doesn't get any
better or any worse in my mind even
though obviously it's a constant like
downward spiral you definitely stick out
like a sore thumb here on skid row yeah
i i hate coming down here man i really
hate coming down here uh because i know
that i know that and i don't dress the
best like i don't think like oh you're
about to be in a spot where people sleep
on the street and beg for their for
their fix you know i mean you're gonna
go down there in a 1200 hoodie like
stand around like this do you talk to
your family at all i called my mom the
other day and
you know it's
right now since i'm
i'm kind of like i'm not strung out
um
i uh i can talk to her
but when i'm bad on like the drugs and i
can't get through like a conversation
with her without crying you know like
because she just wants me to be better
and like they were my enemies for so
long are they giving you tough love
basically yeah yeah
yeah and that's all it is they're very
godly people
they they take counsel from like their
pastor and they've only done what they
thought is right and i i deep down it's
hard for families because help turns
into enabling like that yeah and i've
seen it i've seen it turn into enabling
just like i told you like i'll lie to
them and it's to the point to where they
don't even know if they can help me or
not because
okay is this story true do i help my son
who is saying all these terrible things
that i can't let my son be doing you
know stuck on the side of the road
bleeding
or
do i give him the money and you know
he just gets a fix you know i mean i've
done a lot of these talks i've done
three thousand over over three thousand
i've seen how you think you're as bad as
you can get
you can get a lot of wealth yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a lot worse because
i still look in the mirror and go okay
you look okay but
you know
sexual favors for money when you're
desperate
really bad yeah like really like yeah i
having i've been close i've been close
i've been offered so many things even
just to get like my dick sucked by
someone
and i just remember that kid that grew
up in north carolina to my parents and
i'm like that's not him that's not him
and i've been able to
keep that much self-respect that you
know and i just the thought of that
makes mom makes me
know
i know my mom would cry if she knew that
and and knowing that just has kept me
from it you know yeah your story is
really frustrating because
you tell us your story and you certainly
you have potential yeah you have
the good family to you you know what's
good from bad
and yet i don't know we can't shake you
out of it
and you can't shake yourself out of it i
mean i think i'm on upwards right now
you know doing doordash and i got a
friend that like holds all my money
basically like that's why that's the
person i had to film and show them this
because i would think art your your
music that's my that's but that's what
we're building
we're building into like recording again
because that's another thing like if i
just dive right back in the music
lifestyle bro i'm right back where i
started you know what i mean around you
you were using them too right yeah but
not not heroin as heavily and when i was
it wasn't fentanyl you know what i mean
like it wasn't fed now fedenal is a
totally different demon
you know
and it like with heroin i could put it
down for a couple weeks you know and
maybe come back to it if i [ __ ]
someone offered it to me or if i was
like maybe on a good one spun out needed
to come down but fed and i was like
every day i have to have it
i have to have it to get out of bed i
have to have it to do work i have to
have it to
you know talk to people i have to have
it to make music you know and i need to
stop saying things like have to have it
because i know like i've read rich dad
poor dad you know i mean i know that 90
of all this is in my mindset you know
what i mean and i let my mind i played
the victim for so long i played the
victim and that's what it is i played
the everybody's out together that's what
i after doing so many of these talks
that's what i hear the ones who are
doing well
don't relate to the victim mentality
yeah and the majority of these
interviews i've done where people are
just like
complaining about how they were screwed
over by this that and the other and
their lives have been terrible but but
they're in a terrible spot today
relate to being victims yeah
because they never take the strength for
themselves you gotta take responsibility
for everything even the even where you
get screwed over you take responsibility
for that and you just climb out of it
being a victim like somebody told me is
like giving all your power to somebody
else
and the thought of that you know because
i'm a leader you know i mean i'll
as best as possible i try and do the
right thing and i try and push others to
do the same thing and as soon as i play
he did this to me and it affected me so
badly that i'm here bro where's my power
i gave it all to them you know and i
i can't do that and i think that's one
of the reasons that like
you know for as long as i've been doing
this i i don't look as bad as i should
you know and there there are a lot of
people that have been doing this for
less time than me that looked terrible
you know what do you mean like you look
pretty good yeah for being a fentanyl
addict it's homeless even even even like
peter the guy one of the the skinny guy
that brought here he looked a lot better
like two three weeks ago and i saw him
you know and i'm worried about them you
know because
i'm different from a lot of people out
here dude like i i i i care for people
still
you know i'm i'm not
so far gone that i'm a sociopath that
only can you know when i'm sick yeah i
only care about getting dope you know
what i mean you you want me to scare you
out of it yeah please you like your
teeth i do i do kiss him goodbye
let's just take a look around i'm
already missing half of one in the back
like i remember all of them i know you
like brown teeth no they'll be nubby
brown teeth that'll do it
you know so you know your vanity you
know which we all have yeah
can i be my shoes
it could be yeah i could actually save
you yeah
because i look in the mirror you know
i've got all these scars and
but it could be worse you know like uh i
could have abscess i could have you know
i mean i lost a leg basically i think
that that victim mentality is what's got
to go yeah for you for all of us
for for anybody that's in this situation
because that's what keeps you here it
makes it gives you an excuse for because
then you don't change what you you know
yeah you i and i one thing that people
will say about me and like you've
probably even noticed now is like it's
like
i realize a lot of my problems i have a
lot of good self-insight you get it you
know what i mean and and that's what's
so frustrating for me and everybody else
because there's like there's nothing i
can tell you john you already know
just do it you know just do it you know
and the the
the weak
link in what you're doing is is the
victim yeah you're you're able to accept
that
you were a victim which
you just can't ever do
you can't ever do
yeah because as soon as like i like you
like you said as soon as you know you're
a victim
you lose all your power
and and you don't get that power back
you know and like like rich that poured
out and everything else you know every
other self-help book says it's like it's
all in your mindset and victim
victimhood or ship or whatever it is a
mindset you know
and there's no winners that are blaming
everybody else for their you know
success
people aren't blaming people for their
success there's no victims of success
you know there's only they just take it
as a learning
lesson and they move on and as best as i
can as best i can you know
i i try to
i try to say any situation that goes
negative that goes south i try and say
what was my part in it what did i do
what could i have done differently
and you know
it's it's all well and good to see here
and say that now but like
as best as i can you know i i i want to
become a better person every day because
that's the only way my mom used to say
just do the next right thing and you'll
be fine you know just just the next
right thing whatever it is just do the
next right thing and it's not always
easy but
but it
you know like like you said i know right
from wrong
i know
you know good and evil type so so
finding the next right thing to do is is
not like the most difficult thing in the
world it's just
taking that power in myself to realize
that i am a good person to realize that
i do have talents that that i need to
share with the world and take that power
and just change myself every day until
i'm not trying to run away from anything
with drugs and you know what dude i'm
not even doing that now like even when i
use drugs now it's like i'm
i'm not sad i'm not depressed you know
i'm not getting my kids taken away from
me from dpss you know i'm i'm i'm i've
got a pretty good life even being
homeless you know i can show up to a
party and people just assume that i
belong you know what i mean like i've
i've found myself on vip sections of
shows so many times because people think
i'm with the band or you know just just
from the way i look you know what i mean
and those are things that i i try and
show gratitude for every day like my mom
told me once she said if you woke up
tomorrow and only had the things that
you thanked god for the night before
what would you have
you know and i think i'm gonna have
anything
i mean all right thank you so much for
sharing your story fascinating thank you
very much
you